dear fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr Carol jonai fahir today
you will see an amazing AR research
paper come to life right before us this
is Chad GPT we know that this is an AI
assistant that is so smart it has now
passed a U.S Law School exam and is
considered to be on the level of a
c-plus law student and what is perhaps
even more incredible is that it also
passed coding interview questions
particularly from Google and Amazon and
remember we said that in the first few
days it shot up to 1 million users
incredibly quickly since then get this
now about 100 million people are using
it in just two months after launch wow A
Plus version is available for chatgpt2
which is a subscription and gives you
you Priority Access and some more perks
and now hold on to your papers because
it truly is coming to life oh yes
Microsoft is deploying it to their
search engine Bing which we'll be able
to do so much more however wait a second
if we just type a request we already get
search answers they are right there we
have been able to do this for more than
a decade now so what's new here why is
this interesting what are the advantages
of this AI assistant compared to just
regular search well let's have a look
together the first thing that catches
the eye is that we can ask it questions
that are really specific for instance
here we are asking not just for travel
recommendations but travel
recommendations that are reachable in a
three-hour flight from London and yes I
already see two things here that I
absolutely love one a frequent and
completely Justified criticism of these
AI assistants is that it is sometimes
difficult to know if they are correct or
incorrect they learned from people on
the internet and people on the internet
are sometimes wrong so we should always
double check these results and hold on
to your papers because now we can do
this way easier how well look oh my it
doesn't just give us an answer it also
shows what sources it has used so we can
truly double check these results that is
the way of the true scholar now
Advantage number two this is not just a
search query this is a conversation so
if we wish we can continue the
conversation or make our question even
more specific and three if we do it does
not just lead us to an already existing
guide it distills the knowledge from all
the guides it has seen and gives us
exactly what we want and nothing else no
ads no websites that contain nothing but
text to seduce the search engine to
return that one instead of others just
what we are looking for I absolutely
love it fourth we can also tailor it to
our needs for instance if we are a
little tired of all these math lessons
we can even ask it to present the
answers in the style of a mob boss a
gangster math tutor right at our
fingertips who can process more
information than any of us humans can
and all this for free for all of us what
an incredible tool this will be for
learning in an earlier video I have
already used it to get it to explain my
own papers and mathematics back to me
and I was stunned by how good the
results were however it has some
internal rules as to what it is allowed
to do and what it won't do for us if we
ask it to write a cover letter for a job
it will refuse to write it interestingly
some are already attempting to ask it to
ignore its previous instructions and do
as we ask instead and sometimes it did
things that it was originally not
supposed to do some refer to this as a
prompt injection attack While others
call it jailbreaking the system I hope
these issues will be fixed soon as
Google and Microsoft is planning to
deploy these systems for the whole world
now in the meantime Google has also
announced a sneak peek of their own AI
chatbot which they call Bard we can see
a few results from their media
presentation as you see this can also
answer are burning questions however
according to astrophysicists at Nasa
unfortunately the third answer here was
incorrect one more example that shows us
the importance of such a chatbot showing
its sources and for us to actually check
them once again that is the way of the
true scholar and just imagine what this
will be able to do two more papers down
the line for instance if you look a
couple papers back this is open AI gpt2
the best it could do was finish our
sentences and not nearly as well as a
human would and now build on the back of
gpt3 or maybe something even newer it
can do all this my goodness the bottom
line is that search and finding
information across a huge body of
knowledge that is the internet as we
know it may look very very very
different just a few months from now
searching and organizing knowledge on
the internet will never be the same that
is incredible progress in just a couple
of papers and also incredible attack
transfer wow if you are looking for
inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda now
offers the best prices in the world for
GPU Cloud compute no commitment or
negotiation required just sign up and
launch an instance and hold on to your
papers because with Lambda GPU Cloud you
can get on-demand a100 instances for
1.10 per hour versus 4.10 per hour with
AWS that's 73 savings did I mention they
also offer persistent storage so join
researchers at organizations like apple
MIT and Caltech in using Lambda cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lambdalabs.com papers to
sign up for one of their amazing GPU
instances today thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time